yee-haa is right ET exclusively inside
alexis Ren and Alan Burstyn is rehearsal
from Monday night's country themed
episode of Dancing with the Stars we're
doing a Samba on country Samba to ladies
in the 9news we're really lucky because
we have Lauren Alaina performing talk to
her at all not yet
I've never done that artist performance
yet so maybe on Sunday for sure on
Monday I think this week we're gonna do
like stripped down just a good dancing
Samba is a really hard dance yeah so is
the biggest challenge of doing the Samba
it's the hips and the bow cuz it's like
up down up down country theme going with
it which I know last Monday you guys
said we have no country experience so
what have you been doing to research I
got a hat and I got some boots that's
basically my research method dancing at
the dancer I feel country no what are we
doing for the costume you know I think
we're gonna do more modern country like
pop star country I'm gonna go with the
cowboy hat I know that you hurt your rib
last week so how is that impacting
things this week I mean it's not making
it easier but it's fine I've just been
icing it every night and stretching it
and doing what I can
does that affect the way that you
choreograph this yeah absolutely
I've been doing a much more conscious
job of making sure that we don't do
anything that could affect the rib and
you know not many big bends to the left
because that's where it hurts and no
tricks
there is also dishing on their ballroom
romance people love you together as you
know what's the most challenging part
about having so many fans invested in
this show man's romance it's like a
private matter
ish it's encouraging to see that people
who want to see us
yeah that's cute what do you say it's
sweet like it's just it's really nice to
see people loving us I don't know it's
really really weird I'm like oh my
personally yeah have you guys ever
experienced it at this level that much
interest I have but I usually try to
keep my personal life pretty private so
no I haven't what a minutes it's
flattering to see what is the most
interesting thing you guys have learned
about each other through this process
how easily we get frustrated at each
other but then how easily it's like okay
it's not that big of a deal it's like
literally like okay that's really
tethers neck and then we're laughing the
next five minutes it's like it's really
quick it's up and down up and down it's
really nice to see though cuz I see how
interested and how focused she is and
that's where the frustration comes from
but then it's nice to be like okay if we
just relax we can make it easier and
Monday also means team dances for the
remaining eight couples team dances I am
so excited team Joe down is that what it
is Alexa came up with it perfect why are
you guys the team to be what are your
strengths well we got DeMarcus and
DeMarcus is a physical strength I love I
don't know if you guys know this he got
in eight last week
big deal is a huge deal we all just you
know with that energy coming forward
into the team dance right afterwards it
was just great it was like a high energy
room everyone was happy and you guys are
dancing to Luke Bryan the song is that
right country girl
something yeah shake it
you